JANOW: Well, good morning, everyone.
Pleasure to see you here today.
It's my great privilege to moderate this morning's
discussion with Ambassador Michael Froman.
We'll have a brief conversation, and then
we'll open it up to hear your questions and
comments.
I believe this discussion is on the record.
I think-Ambassador Froman is so well known
to all of us-I will be very brief in my introduction.
But I noticed that he was sworn in as USTR
almost exactly three years ago today, so I-they
may be dog years, seven for one-
FROMAN: It seems like 21, yes.
(Laughter.)
JANOW: -but it is a great accomplishment.
As the U.S. trade representative, he is, of
course, responsible for all trade negotiations,
a spokesman on international trade, principal
interlocutor with Congress and with our major
trading partners.
Before that he was, of course, in the White
House as assistant to the president and deputy
national security advisor for international
economic affairs, and coordinating on international
economic policy and trade, energy finance,
climate, and development and democracy issues,
so an enormous range of responsibilities.
He was sherpa for the G-20/G-8, and had an
earlier period in government as well at Treasury
and in the National Security Council.
So I can't imagine anyone more ready for this
enormous responsibility and playing such an
extraordinary role.
Let me first invite you, if you would, to
help us as we're talking today about TPP and
U.S. leadership in Asia.
Could you help us frame our understanding
of what you see as the key attributes of this
agreement and what it means for the United
States?
FROMAN: Sure.
Well, first of all, thanks for having me.
It's good to see a lot of familiar and generally
friendly faces.
(Laughter.)
So good to-good to be back here at the Council.
Look, the Trans-Pacific Partnership currently
is 12 countries representing about 40 percent
of the global economy.
The agreement eliminates traditional trade
barriers, like tariffs-18,000 tariffs on American
exports; completely eliminates tariffs on
manufactured products; eliminates, or greatly
reduces, or opens up markets to a wide range
of agricultural trade as well.
It's very important when it comes to services
in terms of opening up markets.
We're locking them open so that-we have a
major services surplus from the United States.
We're a globally competitive services provider,
and it opens that as well.
But as important as those are is the rules
that are equally important-the fact that this-the
agreement raises labor and environmental standards
around the world to the highest level ever,
and these are fully enforceable standards;
that it's the first trade agreement to really
take on the digital economy, issues around
e-commerce and the free flow of data across
borders; pushing back on new forms of digital
protectionism, with countries trying to put
walls around the internet or require companies
to move their infrastructure to a country
in order to serve that country.
It takes a major step forward in putting disciplines
on state-owned enterprises, so that when government-owned
corporations compete with our private firms,
they have to do so on a fair and level playing
field or we can impose sanctions on that country.
And so it's very important because this region,
the Asia-Pacific region, it's currently about
a billion middle-class consumers, expected
to grow to 3 billion middle-class consumers
by 2030, some of the largest, fastest growing
economies in the world.
We need to be part of those markets.
And we want to make sure that the rules of
the road for that region reflect our interests
and our values, and that we're not ceding
that role to others, whether it's China or
others.
And so that's why it's so important that we
get it done, and that we get it done this
year.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
I'm sure we'll turn in a few moments to the
question of getting it done, but could you
just say a little bit more about how we should
think about this agreement?
We have trade agreements-free trade agreements
with five of the TPP partners already.
So, in a sense, how much further to we go
in this framework?
And do we think of it primarily as an economic
framework, or is it, in your mind, equally
important as a foreign policy or security
framework?
FROMAN: So, first of all, I think all trade
agreements first and foremost have to be justified
and defended on their economic grounds, what
they do to promote jobs and growth in the
United States, and TPP holds up very well
under that analysis.
The Peterson Institute has estimated it'll
add about $130 billion to GDP when implemented,
that it will increase U.S. exports by about
$350 billion a year.
And the reason why that's important is that
we know that every billion dollars of exports
supports somewhere between 5(,000) and 7,000
U.S. jobs, and those jobs pay up to 18 percent
more on average than non-export related jobs.
So if you're worried about wage stagnation,
you're worried about income inequality, the
majority of the benefits of this agreement
go to workers, both skilled and unskilled
workers, according to the Peterson Institute.
And this is one way of making sure that we're
addressing those issues.
It is equally important on a strategic level
and from a position of U.S. leadership.
You know, I mentioned the rules in TPP, but
as we speak there are-countries are moving
ahead with their own trade agreements, their
own regional arrangements.
And whether it's RCEP, which is the mega-regional
agreement that China's leading, it doesn't
include labor and environmental provisions,
it doesn't include disciplines on state-owned
enterprises, it doesn't commit to a free and
open internet.
And so it's very important that, from a U.S.
leadership perspective, we're there helping-working
with our like-minded partners in the region
to set these rules of the road and not giving
that up.
You know, also, you-people like Prime Minister
Lee, who has said, if you can't deal with
us on cars and services and agriculture, can
we depend on you when it comes to security
and military matters?
And I think that's a very important sentiment.
These countries very much want to be embedded
with us, or want us embedded with them in
the region, both for economic purposes-so
that they can diversify their partnerships,
diversify their markets-but also, very importantly,
from a strategic perspective.
And they see this partnership as having broader
political and strategic ramifications.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
So do you see the agreement as provoking an
economic reform agenda in TPP countries that
is meaningful to the United States?
FROMAN: I think that's absolutely right.
I mean, whether it's in Japan, where the-Prime
Minister Abe has viewed TPP as part of his
third arrow in Abenomics, the structural reform
agenda, and sees TPP as encouraging the kind
of reform of the agrarian sector that he has
been advocating for; or in Vietnam, where
the Vietnamese leadership has agreed to allow
independent unions for the first time, or
to reform or to use TPP to reform their state-owed
enterprise sector, or to raise their IP standards
because they want to become a more innovative
economy.
So, from country to country, they've looked
at this as a way of helping to support a domestic
reform agenda.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
You know, I think the consequences of a loss
of American leadership is a bit of an ephemeral
concept to convince, you know, the electorate.
And I wonder, how do you-how do you engage
that?
How do you think the consequences really are
if, in fact, this doesn't go forward, and
the U.S. has negotiated this, and countries
have made commitments in good faith?
What are the consequences?
FROMAN: Well, first, there are economic consequences.
Again, the Peterson Institute has estimated
that even just a one-year delay would be a
permanent cost to the U.S. economy of $94
billion.
That's about a $700 tax on every American
household.
Then there's the cost to U.S. leadership.
Again, whether-you know, we have been the
primary driver of a rules-based, international,
open system since the Second World War.
It's allowed countries like Japan and throughout
Europe to rebuild themselves.
It's allowed developing countries to become
emerging economies.
It's lifted-it's help lift hundreds of millions
of people out of poverty.
And that system is something we can't take
for granted.
We shouldn't be complacent about it because
there are other alternatives being promoted
out there-more statist, more mercantilist
systems.
And we think it's very important that the
rules-based system, where every country has
certain rights, where there's dispute settlement
that they can count on, where it's not just
big countries pushing little ones around,
that that's a very important part of a stable
and prosperous Asia-Pacific region, and more
generally an international system.
And then, thirdly, there are the strategic
costs.
Prime Minister Key of New Zealand has said,
you know, the rest of the world isn't going
to just stand by.
Beijing will fill whatever void we create,
and other countries will feel the need to
line up accordingly.
And that cannot be in the interest of the
United States.
And so, as people are critical of TPP-I mean,
it's been interesting.
There's been a lot of criticism of China in
the-in the recent debate, and I think a lot
of that criticism is well-founded.
And it's something that we need to constantly
press China on: to live up to a rules-based
system, implement their obligations, and be
prepared to take enforcement actions where
they-where they don't.
But TPP is one of the greatest tools we have
for raising the standards in this region.
And as other countries raise the standards,
it'll force China to up its game as well in
order to compete.
And that's in all of our interests.
So it doesn't make a lot of sense to me to
be critical of China on one hand and then
be willing to give up one of our most important
tools for creating the environment around
China that will be important to raise China's
performance as well.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
So do you see this as triggering China into
altering its own practices?
Or do you think it accentuates this argument
in China that the U.S. is trying to contain
China?
FROMAN: We've been very open with the Chinese
from the start of this negotiation.
This isn't directed against them.
It's not an effort to contain them.
It is an effort to raise standards in the
region and around the world.
And the Chinese have followed the negotiations
in great detail.
We've kept them very much up to date throughout
the negotiations.
And I think, ultimately, again, because as
countries like Vietnam and Malaysia and the
other countries who have now signaled they'd
like to join TPP in the future.
You know, we have 12 countries in the agreement.
You know, we've heard from another 12 or 13
economies that they would like to join TPP
in the future, or they'd like to have conversations
about joining TPP in the future.
As this becomes the set of rules that defines
what a high-standard economy is all about,
I think it's going to help encourage a competitive
race to the top.
And that's good-I think, again, good for all
of us.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Let's turn to the United States.
And obviously, trade has, you know, been negatively
cast in the election process by both of the
candidates thus far.
So what is your strategy for advancing this
agreement in this very difficult political
context?
And how do you appeal to the American public
to recognize the values?
FROMAN: Well, first, I think the good news
is that, as-now that the agreement is done,
it's been out there in public since November,
people have had a chance to dig into it, they're
seeing the value that's in there, what's in
it for different constituencies or different
stakeholders.
And those stakeholders are beginning to speak
out.
So you have broad support across virtually
the whole economy, whether it's the agriculture
sector; the manufacturing sector; the high-tech
sector; the business sector, broadly; the
small-business sector, very importantly, because
we have a real focus in the agreement on helping
small businesses engage in global trade.
And that support is beginning to trickle through
to members of Congress, as well.
I'm spending a lot of my time, when I'm not
traveling abroad, up on the Hill talking to
members of Congress.
And, again, the good news is, as they dig
into the details and they see what's in it
for their constituents, which is their primary
driving-the driving force behind their decision-making,
they are seeing both the potential-the positive
upside-and what's at risk in not getting it
done.
You know, just to give you-to give you one
example, the cattlemen, the beef-the beef
producers.
Because Australia already has an FTA with
Japan, and so it faces a lower tariff exporting
beef into Japan than we do, we're losing market
share.
And that's going to continue until TPP gets
put into place.
So we're losing over $120 million a year of
beef exports to Japan.
As constituents really dig into that and say
there's a lot in here for us in getting this
done and there's a lot to lose if this gets
delayed, that-those voices on Capitol Hill
are being heard.
And I think, at the end of the day, there
will be the necessary support to get it done.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
So, you know, it seems to me that, ever since
NAFTA, administrations have had to justify
trade agreements, you know, state by state
and sector by sector, stitching together the
necessary coalitions.
Where is the heart of your coalition around
this, do you think?
Or is it really very broad-based?
FROMAN: Well, it's pretty-it's pretty broad-based.
There are regional elements to it, but again,
I think the-one of the things I'm most proud
of is that we worked very hard not to leave
any sector behind.
So we have the support of the textile producers
in the United States-this is the first time
they've really been unified behind a trade
agreement-and the apparel importers, the people
who rely on imported clothing.
We have the support of the domestic footwear
producers and the footwear importers.
We have the broad support of the agricultural
community, with very few exceptions, of the
manufacturers, of the service providers.
The technology companies have now come out,
the internet association, the apps developers,
Google, et cetera.
And all of that has been very, very positive.
And so, again, as members of Congress are
hearing about that and beginning to get a
feel for what's really at stake, there-I think
the necessary support will be there.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
And could you speak about where you see the
opposition?
You know, I've heard, of course, sectoral
opposition-you know, concern by biologics,
you know, Senator Hatch; concern about investor-state,
which is a bigger, more systemic kind of concern;
and, of course, by labor, although you have
ambitious labor provisions in here.
So could you speak about the opposition?
FROMAN: Sure.
There are a handful of issues that Congress
identified when the agreement was done that
they wanted us to make sure we were fully
addressing.
And, bit by bit, we've been able to address
those.
So there were issues around pork and issues
around dairy, and those groups are now fully
supportive.
There were issues around the financial services
sector and the free flow of data, and I think
we're quite close to reaching a resolution
of that issue.
I think the main outstanding issue right now
has to do-and you mentioned biologics, which
is a(n) intellectual property rights issue.
And we are working with members of Congress
and with the industry to try and find solutions
there to reassure them about the issues that
they care about without reopening the agreement
or trying to renegotiate the agreement.
You know, I think in terms of the opposition,
as you mentioned, there are a lot of things
in here that are very strong on labor, the
strongest labor provisions ever.
The Vietnamese-if you look at what the Vietnamese
have agreed to in terms of allowing independent
unions that can elect their own leaders, control
their own finances, conduct strikes, affiliate
with whom they choose, again, assistance from
outside from the AFL or the ILO or others,
it's really quite groundbreaking.
And some of the other labor measures that
countries have taken on on their own to address
outstanding issues have been really quite
groundbreaking.
But it is true that organized labor is strongly
and unified against it.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Could you speak a moment about the strategy-legislative
strategy for advancing this forward?
I mean, the expectation is that this is-that
you're pursuing a lame-duck strategy.
And, you know, I would just observe that the
president of the United States always ultimately
has to really weigh in and make it a priority
to get over the finish line.
What do you see in the six months ahead?
FROMAN: Well, we'd like to get it done as
quickly as possible, as early as possible.
And we're working with congressional leaders
and with the leaders of our committees-the
Finance Committee and the Ways and Means Committee-to
chart that pathway forward-laying the groundwork,
doing the preparatory work, drafting the bills,
drafting the reports that need to get done-so
that, when that window of opportunity opens,
we'll be ready to walk through it.
And that's what our-that's what the work over
the next few months is going to take.
And again, I think there's a lot of desire
to get it done.
There's a recognition that if it doesn't get
done this year, it's unclear when it would
get done and how long it would have to linger.
And that has serious costs, as we talked about,
both economically and politically and strategically.
And so our strategy is just to work with individual
members, make sure they know what's in the
agreement, that they appreciate what's in
it for their constituents or stakeholders
that they care about, and then move forward
when the time-when the time is right.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
OK.
FROMAN: And the president-and you mentioned
the president; president has been very much-he's
fully invested in this.
We have a whole-of-White-House, whole-of-Cabinet
effort underway with hundreds of events around
the country by Cabinet, sub-Cabinet officials.
If you haven't seen it already, I commend
you the president's performance on Jimmy Fallon
last week where he slow-jammed the news with
a good plug for TPP right in the middle of
it.
So he's very much fully invested in this effort
as well.
JANOW: OK.
Well, that's a first, I think.
FROMAN: That is a first.
(Laughter.)
JANOW: You know, one of the things you didn't
mention which I know has gotten some attention
and which has some controversy around it is
currency.
Could you speak to what-there is a currency
agreement of some sort.
I have not read it myself, I must admit.
But it doesn't apply sanctions, I believe.
Does it take you forward in collaboration
in a new way?
And, you know, this is really not an area
that trade has dealt with historically.
FROMAN: I think-that's right.
This is the first time we have an agreement
on currency among a group of trading partners
to an agreement.
And it's-really, it's a three-part agreement.
It lays out criteria of what appropriate exchange
rate policy is, drawing from the IMF and the
G-20 and the G-7.
It requires certain transparency so that for
the first time, we'll have visibility into
how central banks intervene in the market,
how often they intervene, when they intervene.
And then it has an accountability mechanism
where the finance authorities get together
on a regular basis and assess each other's
performance against those criteria.
So it's the first time ever we've had something
like this.
I think it's a major step forward.
And the Treasury Department negotiated this
with its counterparts around the TPP countries.
What it doesn't do at the end of the day is
end with trade sanctions, which is what some
of the critics have advocated.
And the reason for that is, well, we may have
a particular view of what currency manipulation
looks like; other countries have-in our view
wrongly-but other countries have looked at
our monetary policy, quantitative easing,
and have said, that has the same effect on
relative currency values.
And we would never subject our Federal Reserve
and our monetary policy to a trade tribunal
and trade sanctions, and no other country
would either.
So it does stop short of that.
But between this new agreement and some other
tools that Congress gave the Treasury Department
in the recently passed customs bill, I think
we have more teeth, the Treasury Department
has more teeth to deal with the issues of
currency manipulation than ever before, and
I think it is a significant step forward.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Let me ask you two other quick questions before
we open it up.
They're a little bit more sector-specific.
You've alluded to disciplines around state-owned
enterprises.
And could you just say more about that?
Is that-some of those have dealt with transparency
and also procurement practices.
We have an international procurement agreement.
China is not yet a party to that.
So what is this framework doing that we don't
have at the multilateral or other level?
FROMAN: So this goes further.
It looks at both the purchases and sales of
products and services, so it goes beyond goods
to cross-border services and says, if you're
a state-owned enterprise, you've got to-and
you engage in commercial activity, you have
to engage on a commercial basis.
And if you don't, and if the noncommercial
assistance that you receive from your government,
whether it's subsidies or other measures,
has an adverse effect on a private firm, we
have a trade action against you.
And that adverse effect could be us trying
to sell something into Vietnam and a Vietnamese
SOE distorting the market.
It could be a Vietnamese SOE operating in
the United States having a green field investment
in the United States but undercutting our
private firms.
Or it could be in a third TPP country.
And that's never been done before.
And so in any of those cases, if it has an
adverse effect on our private firms, then
we can bring a trade action against the government
and ultimately impose sanctions if it doesn't
get rectified.
And we think that's important because-and
again, in a lot of the public debate we're
hearing about trade, there's an underlying
theme that people worry that the system isn't
fair or that other countries aren't playing
by the same rules that we play by.
And this is one of those ways of rectifying
that by saying that a state-owned enterprise
competing against a private firm has to play
by the same rules of fairness than anybody
else, and if they don't, we have an enforcement
action against their government.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Very good.
Let me ask you a bit more about the digital
economy because more and more I think is trade,
whether it's services or manufactured goods,
is really implicated by the ability to have
data flow across borders.
If I'm understanding, this agreement is the
first that really is going to prohibit data
localization.
Is that fair?
FROMAN: That's right.
I think that's right.
Look, it's very important because as you mention,
first of all, this isn't just about tech firms
and their importance of having data across
borders.
Data is part of everything.
It's part of services.
It's part of manufacturing.
And firms need to be able to move data from
one jurisdiction to another.
And this is the first time that there is a
prohibition on data localization, prohibition
on forcing a country to have servers in every
market that they want to provide services
in in order to be able to participate so they
can have their data stored where it's secure,
where there is integrity to the network.
There are a whole series of other provisions
about not imposing duties on digital products
like apps, and so making sure that there is
a free flow of innovation in that regard as
well.
And then from a small business perspective-you
know, most small and medium-size businesses
don't have widespread distribution systems
or sales forces around the world.
They rely on e-commerce.
And when they're selling something from-on
Etsy in Brooklyn from here to somebody in
Australia-and I met with a number of Etsy
producers who were-who were doing just that-they're
using telecom services, software services,
electronic payment services, express delivery
services.
And all those services are covered in this
agreement.
So we've worked very hard to make sure that
the rules are such that, again, support the
continued development of the digital economy,
including for e-commerce, especially for small
and medium-size businesses so they can all
take advantage of the opening of the markets
that we've been able to secure.
JANOW: Thank you very much.
With that, why don't I open it up for questions
and comments-questions, not comments-from
our very distinguished audience.
And if you could just briefly identify yourself
and ask a brief question.
Sir.
Q: Good morning.
Thank you.
Ted Pulling from JPMorgan Asset Management.
You mentioned the window of opportunity which
you need to get this passed before the election.
Can you tell us approximately when that window
of opportunity is?
There is not a lot of time.
FROMAN: Well, I think Leader McConnell of
the Senate has made clear publicly that he
doesn't want to see a vote before the election.
So that really means-from the Senate perspective,
anyway-in the lame-duck period.
But to even do this in the lame duck, you
want to do as much of the preparatory work
as possible under trade promotion authority
beforehand, and that's what we're working
on now.
JANOW: Other questions.
Yes.
Q: Tim Ferguson with Forbes.
So both major candidates are pledging to rework
the agreement in some way once they are elected,
once he or she is elected.
What kind of wiggle room is there actually
to do that reworking without renegotiating,
if that is the event?
FROMAN: This is a much more complicated agreement
than I think anything we tried before.
You know, as Merit mentioned, half the countries
we already have FTAs with, and-so you're not
trading market access for agreement to a set
of rules; you're just building support for
those rules.
This wasn't an agreement where eight or nine
countries agreed on everything and it was
just a process of pulling the other three
countries over the time.
This was an agreement where every single provision
had a different set of parties who were in
favor or against it and you had to build consensus
issue by issue.
And as a result, it's a very-every country
feels like it found the right balance, and
it has to justify that balance at home politically
as well.
And so pulling the thread on one issue I'm
very concerned will lead to the unraveling
across several other issues.
So I do not think this is an agreement that
can be easily renegotiated or re-opened.
That doesn't mean that in the process of implementation-and
we have a robust process of making sure countries
are meeting their obligations; we work with
Congress on that-that there aren't things
that we can do to give reassurance that we're
addressing issues with the countries and with
Congress.
But I think opening up the Pandora's Box of
renegotiation I think will ultimately lead
to it unraveling itself.
JANOW: Professor Fox.
Q: Hello.
Eleanor Fox, New York University.
I want to push further on Dean Janow's question
to you about opposition to free trade agreements.
And it's more than TPP, but it's focused on
TPP a lot right now.
You seem rather sanguine when you say people
should just look at the agreement and see
the benefits.
And we've talked to all the stakeholders.
And all they have to do is look and see the
benefits.
And yet, isn't there a sense that they have
looked-that is, for example, our candidates
for president-that they have looked and they
don't see the benefits?
Why is that?
What is this gap of populist opposition?
Is it, in part, a concern that people lose
their jobs here and now, even though labor
wins, but particular people lose.
And perhaps they feel not enough is done to
compensate them?
I think, actually, it goes deeper and more
philosophically and would like to know what
you think.
But specifically, are the losers going to
be helped in some way that will satisfy them?
And then generally, is there yet a bigger
gap of just philosophical opposition to freer
trade on a thought and belief that our country
is worse off?
FROMAN: So it's a very good question, and
a very timely one.
If you ask most economists-well, if you look
at the economic situation in our country,
we've seen a lot of improvement over the last
six or seven years in terms of unemployment
has been cut in half, we've had, what is it,
75 months in a row of private sector job creation
and we're growing 2 and 3 percent.
We created 14 million new jobs.
All that's very good.
At the same time, we've seen wage stagnation
for the last 15 years or so.
This is only beginning to turn up.
I think it's gone up-wages have gone up about
2 1/2 percent last year.
And they're on the same track again this year.
We've seen widening income inequality.
And I think those have contributed very significantly
to the populist feeling that you cite.
Now, if you talk to most economists, they'll
tell you, if you look at the changing nature
of the workforce, it's more automation than
globalization, but certainly globalization
plays a role.
You don't get to vote on automation.
Nobody gets to vote on the next generation
or computers, or on the next generation of
robots that might affect the workforce.
You don't really get to vote on globalization.
Globalization is a force.
It's the product of the containerization of
shipping, the spread of broadband, the integration
of economies like China and Eastern Europe
that used to be closed to the world and are
now part of the global economy.
You do get to vote on trade agreements.
And so trade agreements become the proxy,
become the vessel into which people pour,
I think, their quite legitimate concerns about
the changing nature of the workforce and their
concerns about wages and income inequality.
Now, our perspective is while you don't get
to vote on globalization, trade agreements
is now you shape globalization.
Without trade agreements, we are an open economy
already.
We have very little protection here.
Our averaged applied tariff is 1.4 percent.
We don't use regulations as a disguised barrier
to trade.
So when we grow, we bring in imports from
all over the world.
We compete right now with low wage countries
around the world.
With trade agreements, we have the opportunity
of removing barriers to those markets so that
we can increase our exports.
And we have the opportunity to raise standards
in those countries so there's a more level
playing field.
And that's really what's been driving behind
the TPP.
It's a recognition that we do live in a global
economy, that we can't put that genie back
in the bottle.
But through trade agreements, we can take
action that reflects our interests, reflects
our values, and shape the global economy in
a way that's more to the benefit of our workers.
JANOW: May I ask one follow-up question?
You know, in other periods of fashioning a
coalition around international trade, you
know, the administration arguably had more
tools than you do at this point in an administration,
in the current environment, whether it was
trade adjustment assistance or other kinds
of tools to kind of buttress support or benefit
even constituencies in certain states or whatever
to reach the political compromises necessary.
Do you have such tools?
FROMAN: Well, when we secured trade promotion
authority last year from Congress, we were
actually able to get a renewal of trade adjustment
assistance.
I'm sorry I didn't answer that part of your
question.
So we had a six-year renewal of the trade
adjustment assistance program.
It was expanded to cover not just manufacturing
workers but service workers, and not just
workers who might be displaced by a trade
agreement but workers displaced by anything
happening in the global economy.
So whether it's coming from China or India,
where we don't have trade agreements, or whether
it's coming from an FTA partner.
But to the professor's point, there's always
more than can and should be done.
And whether it's investing in education, and
skills building, and infrastructure, and all
the things that we know are important to building
a highly productive economy here, there is
more-there is more to be done.
It's something that we've always advocated
for.
And I think it's something that's getting
a lot of attention, properly, in the current
debate.
JANOW: Thank you.
Sir.
Q: Thank you.
Earl Carr, representing Momentum Advisors.
I was at a meeting with one of the key negotiators
for TPP.
And she mentioned that Malaysia and Vietnam
would be best positioned to gain the most
economic value from this agreement.
Would you agree with that assessment?
FROMAN: I think the Peterson Institute was
probably the most in-depth report on TPP,
says on a percentage base-as a percentage
of their economy in terms of GDP growth or
growth in exports, those two economies are
likely to benefit the most.
We benefit the most in absolute terms, but
of course we're the largest economy in the
world.
They benefit the most in percentage terms.
It's not particularly surprising, because
they countries that benefit the most are those
who are eliminating the most barriers.
They're the ones that are most protected now
and will be having to liberalize their economy,
and they'll get the greatest gains from that
liberalization.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Professor Feldstein.
Q: Hi.
I thought one of the most significant things
you said is there really isn't scope for renegotiation
of the agreement.
So whatever the agreement is has to be voted
eventually up or down.
Secretary Clinton has expressed her lack of
support for the agreement in its current form.
So it sounds like you can't change the agreement
after she becomes elected, if she gets elected,
in order to get her support.
So does that mean that the strategy for getting
her to say, well, taken as a whole I like
this deal, is in some of these collateral
things-changes in manpower programs or other
things-since you can't change the basic agreement?
FROMAN: Well, I won't comment on any particular
candidate, and I certainly can't speak for
Secretary Clinton and what the perspective-what
her perspective might be going forward.
What I can say is that this is the highest
standard agreement ever negotiated, again,
across these various provisions; that I do
believe because of the complexities of the
agreement, the number of countries, the number
of issues, the dynamics of the negotiation
themselves that renegotiation's not an option.
And by the way, these countries have their
own politics around these issues.
And they're all going through their own ratification
procedures.
And we need to take that into account as well
as they move forward, even as we're encouraging
our Congress to do so as well.
I do think there are things that can be done
outside the agreement, as you mentioned, that
will address the broader concerns about how
to make sure the American workforce is prepared
to compete in the global economy and in the
TPP-in a TPP world.
And I also believe that through the implementation
process we can work with Congress, with stakeholders,
with our trading partners to make sure that,
as we're interpreting elements of the agreement,
as countries are bringing their systems into
compliance with the agreement, that we're
doing everything necessary to ensure that
those issues are addressed.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
In the far back, please.
Q: Hi.
Mario-
JANOW: Is the microphone-
Q: Oh, thank you.
Sorry.
I'm Mario Calvo-Platero, Sole 24 Ore.
I just wanted to hear whether there is any
progress on TTIP, on the transatlantic agreement,
and whether there is a chance to do something
before the administration will go out.
Thank you.
FROMAN: There has been progress-actually,
quite a bit of progress-over the last eight
months, I would say.
And there is a chance to get it done this
year.
And that is our objective, is to try-it won't
go through Congress, but to get it agreed
to over the course of this administration.
To do that, it's going to require continued
progress along the same kind of accelerated
pace that we've seen over the last few months.
It's also going to require some creative and
pragmatic and non-ideological approaches to
resolving what inevitably are the hardest
outstanding issues.
We've got the political will.
And the president, when he was in Hanover
a couple of months ago, and then again at
the G-7, made very clear that the U.S. is
fully committed to doing everything we can
do to try and reach an agreement this year.
We hope that the Europeans are similarly focused.
They have a lot on their plate at the moment,
and a lot of concerns and countervailing forces,
whether it's Brexit vote this week, or the
migrant crisis, or the hangover of the Greek
crisis, or the rise of populism, or the spread
of referenda, or the euro-skepticism that
are very much affecting their day-to-day lives.
We hope that they've got the necessary focus
to get-and the political will to get this
done as well.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
In the front, David Sandalow.
Q: Hi.
David Sandalow.
Columbia School of International and Public
Affairs.
Assume that TPP does enter into force, how
do you see China relating to the agreement
over time?
FROMAN: Well, our view has always been this
is not directed against China.
It's not about containing China.
It's about setting high standards.
But as other countries adopt these high standard-whether
it's Vietnam, Malaysia, or others, I think
I mentioned that there's another dozen-or-so
countries who have indicated they'd like to
potentially join TPP as well-it's going to
require China to up its game as well to be
competitive.
You know, when neighboring countries are offering
better intellectual property rights protection,
protection against trade secret theft, real
dispute settlement-recourse to real dispute
settlement, new stable labor and environmental
environments to operate in, that's going to
require a race to-that's going to lead to
a race to the top for the region.
That's our goal.
And that will require China to up its game
as well.
And I think that's all-that's in all of our
interests.
JANOW: One follow-up question about China.
I think the administration has now had something
like 23 or 24 rounds of negotiations on the
investment-bilateral investment agreement.
And I wonder where you think that stands and
how it intersects with a broader trade agreement.
Some argue, you know, that it can be viewed
as a stepping stone.
Is that your view or do you think that's a
Chinese view?
Or do you think on its own is what's the driver
of its completion?
FROMAN: Well, I think a high-standard bilateral
investment treaty would require some very
significant reforms of the Chinese economic
system.
And that-we're having that dialogue with them.
Just last week they were in Washington again,
and gave us a revised-let's call it a negative
list, which is the list of sectors where they're
not committing to openness.
So we want to keep that list as narrow and
as short as possible.
And we're in the process of assessing that
proposal.
And we'll be further engaging with them actively
over the course of the summer and into the
fall.
I think if we can achieve a high-standard
agreement you're moving from a world in which
everything is prohibited unless it's expressly
approved to one where everything's approved
unless expressly regulated or prohibited.
And that's a significant change in terms of
getting the government out of the business
of managing the economy.
I think separate from TPP it really is a data
point or indication of China's commitment
to reform.
And that's the kind of dialogue we're having
with them, is how far they're willing to go
to demonstrate that they are serious about
allowing market forces to play a dispositive
effect on decision making in their system.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Do you see that agreement as offering some
protections or a better context for Chinese
investment in the U.S., from a U.S. perspective?
FROMAN: Oh, it's a bilateral agreement.
We already have a very open investment regime.
We don't have any-very few kinds of restrictions
that we face in other countries.
And obviously in China we face enormous numbers
of restrictions.
You know, our CFIUS procedure, the Committee
on Foreign Investment in the United States,
reviews mergers and acquisitions from a very
specific national security perspective.
So we already-China investment in the U.S.
has grown dramatically over the last several
years.
They've had little problem investing in assets
here.
And I think the BIT will help institutionalize
that.
But we're already a very open economy when
it comes to investment.
And we encourage investment from foreign investors
in the United States.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
I was thinking, though, in terms of offering
a vehicle for structured conversations around
problems when they arise, whether they're
perceived as arising in China or arising here,
and whether the BIT is really a vehicle that
helps you get there.
FROMAN: We have a series of vehicles.
And we just came back from the Strategic and
Economic Dialogue in Beijing a couple weeks
ago.
And investment issues were on that agenda.
And we always share perspectives, our concerns
about problems that our investors are having
in their market, and they raise concerns about
our market as well.
And so I think it is important that we continue
to have that dialogue and address those issues.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Thank you.
Over here, please.
Q: My name is Masazumi Nakayama, Citigroup.
I have a question about ISDS growth.
And some countries' public opinion expressed
a fear of ISDS growth because a country thinks
the U.S. always wins in the international
dispute.
How can we help them feel more comfortable
about ISDS growth?
FROMAN: Well, first, I think-ISDS is investor-state
dispute settlement.
It's the mechanism of mutual international
arbitration where investors are able to protect
themselves from expropriation or other discriminatory
actions in a foreign market.
Our perspective on it, first, is we provide
under our Constitution, the fifth amendment,
the Takings Clause protection to all domestic
and foreign investors against expropriation
without compensation.
And what ISDS is really about is making sure
that our investors, when they're operating
abroad, have a similar level of basic protection.
But we share a number of the concerns that
have been raised about ISDS over the years.
And in fact, since 2000, in each of our subsequent
agreements we have been working to reform
ISDS, whether it's raising the standards and
tightening them up, adding various procedural
and substantive safeguards, increasing transparency
of the proceedings, closing loopholes that
we found in other countries' agreements, all
of those have been part of our agenda really
for the last 15, 16 years.
In the 30-plus years we've had agreements
with ISDS, and we have 51 agreements to which
we're a party with ISDS, we've had a sum total
of 17 cases brought against the United States-13
cases to conclusion, and the government has
never lost a case.
We've had no cases brought in the last six
years.
And so while ISDS use generally may be going
up around the world, we're not seeing a big
influx of cases in the United States against
U.S. government action or U.S. regulation.
And I think that's, in part, because we focus
so much in our agreements on raising the standards
and adding these safeguards, and closing these
loopholes.
Whereas, you know, there are 3,200 agreements
around the world that have ISDS, and they
have varying standards.
Our approach to TPP has been let's use TPP,
again, as a way of raising the standards for
ISDS.
And if TPP doesn't move forward, then you're
stuck with the existing standards.
So if you don't like the current agreements
with ISDS, you should want to move forward
with TPP because it actually tightens it and
reforms it further.
But little things, like-lots of little things.
An investor's expectations of profits alone
cannot be a basis of a suit.
That's a reform in TPP.
An investor's expectations that regulations
won't change, alone, cannot be the basis of
a suit.
The governments have a right to regulate.
That's in TPP.
Those are the kinds of reforms that we've
been able to negotiate with our trading partners
that we think overall makes ISDS a mechanism
that appropriately protects investors while
ensuring that governments can take the actions
they need to take in a bona fide way for regulation.
JANOW: I, myself, have arbitrated a number
of these, as you know.
And at least under NAFTA, you know, they've
been open hearings where, you know, anyone
can show up.
And I think some allow for amicus curiae submissions
by interested parties and so on.
So, you know, they're not the kind of secret
forum that is often said.
FROMAN: In TPP, we've agreed to webcast them.
JANOW: Yeah, that was-
FROMAN: That makes them more transparent than
the U.S. Supreme Court.
JANOW: Mmm hmm, yeah.
Well, there are reasons as a judge I would
say why a webcast is not a wonderful-(laughter).
Yes, please.
Q: Leila Heckman from Lebenthal.
The candidate Hillary says she's going to-she
would renegotiate TPP.
What aspects of TPP do you think she's referring
to?
FROMAN: Again, I can't speak for her.
I think she has flagged a couple of issues
in particular, including the currency issue
that Merit mentioned, including ISDS, although
it's unclear what part of it she'd want to
renegotiate.
She has cited pharmaceutical provisions.
She feels we did too much in the agreement
to protect pharmaceuticals.
And she's flagged the rules of origin issue.
Those are the four that I'm aware of.
JANOW: Can I just ask a political question
further?
You know, first term of the Obama administration,
obviously you're dealing with the global financial
crisis, domestic issues; trade was not that
visible.
But the second administration has been so
focused on trade under your leadership.
As you look ahead, and if TPP does not go
forward, or even if it does, imagine how any
administration, do you see that it would just
languish for a full term?
Or how do you imagine that this might unfold
for a new administration?
FROMAN: Well, look, I think there is a certain
urgency to getting it done-to getting it done
this year.
As you said, we really turned to doing Korea/Colombia/Panama
about three years into the administration,
and trade was not as prominent a campaign
issue in 2008 as it is in 2016.
Right now, you've got a president, a majority
leader of the Senate, and a speaker of the
House who are all pro trade and who've all
been involved in pursuing this agenda.
And, you know, that could well be different
a year from now.
And so I think that really does put a focus
on doing everything we can to get this done
this year.
JANOW: Absolutely.
There's a question here.
Yeah.
Q: Hi.
Julien Tizorin from UniCredit.
Little question regarding the energy sector.
What does-TPP will provide for the energy
sector in the U.S., especially given that
now, you know, exporting crude oil is starting
just a little bit-there's been a lot of investment
in terms of exporting energy and especially
to countries where-you know, which are related
to the TPP?
We've also seen the U.S. production capacity
to be very flexible in terms of the collapse
of the oil price over the past few months.
What would TPP really allow?
And how much is it going to drive some of
the U.S. exports, as well?
FROMAN: TPP itself does not have an energy
chapter or deal with energy issues itself.
I think under our U.S. law, for example, the
Natural Gas Act, exports of natural gas to
FTA partners, who also give us access to their
market, is presumed to be in the-in the national
interest or the public interest.
And so there's a separate track of licensing
FTA partners for export from non-FTA partners
for export.
And the Department of Energy-David knows this
much better than I do-has a process for evaluating
those licenses accordingly.
But the trade agreement itself does not actually
deal with energy trade.
JANOW: Sir.
Q: Good morning.
Away from TPP, but to take advantage of your
presence here with us, would you share with
us your thoughts and insights into the consequences
of Brexit, should the vote go that way-what
the consequences for the U.K. and for the
EU might be?
JANOW: And if you can bring that to TPP, that
would be even better.
(Laughter.)
FROMAN: Maybe to TTIP.
I mean, look, this is obviously a decision
that the British people themselves need to
make.
But we've made clear-the president made clear
when he was in London that we believe a strong
U.K. and a strong and unified European Union
is in everybody's interest: in the interest
of the U.K., in the interest of Europe, and
in our interest.
We want a strong Europe that is outwardly
focused and capable of being a partner of
ours in dealing with a whole range of global
issues.
And that remains-that remains our position,
but it is for the British people to decide.
And as I sort of alluded to in our-in the
TTIP question earlier, we want to make sure
that Europe has the ability to engage in a
broad set of issues going forward, and do
have concerns about how Brexit might play
into that.
JANOW: So is that-as a point of departure,
imagine we have TPP and TTIP in existence.
How do you see these rule frameworks interacting
with each other?
The argument used to be made that these would
escalate into something else over time.
I don't think we've seen any evidence of that,
but we've seen other ways in which they can
be reinforcing.
So how do you see these rule frameworks?
Because they're not identical, either in the
coverage or in structure.
FROMAN: They may not be-end up being identical,
but they-our goal is for them both to advance
the goal of raising standards around the world.
And if we can do it with TPP and TTIP, that's
two-thirds of the global economy.
Then you've got the countries who've already
indicated that they want to join TPP, and
even some who've said they want to join TTIP
once it gets completed, so you can see that
growing above two-thirds.
When you've got two-thirds or more of the
global economy saying, here's a good framework
for the digital economy, for intellectual
property rights, for state-owned enterprise
disciplines, for science-based rulemaking,
it makes it much easier, then, to multilaterlize
that.
Those countries have already gone through
the challenges of getting to those positions
domestically.
They brought their stakeholders along.
And then it makes it easier and easier to
make that a multilateral role.
And that's ultimately-our objective is-I mean,
the highest and best form of trade liberalization
is the multilateral system.
We've seen it stymied over the last 15 years
for a variety of reasons in the Doha Round,
but we now feel that the WTO is at a moment
in time when it can actually look at new approaches
to old issues and new issues it can take on.
And as these mega-regional agreements are
put in place, we think that helps sort of
create building blocks that ultimately might
help strengthen the multilateral system as
well.
JANOW: Mmm hmm.
Sir, last question.
Q: Jeff Glueck from Foursquare.
Hi, Mike.
Good to see you again.
FROMAN: Good to see you.
Q: And a salute, by the way, unrelated, to
your Kids v. Cancer work.
I'm a big fan of all that you and your wife
have done on that.
You alluded to the science-based regulation,
and a lot of the criticism of TPP has been
around usurping sort of democratic and sovereign
and evolving scientific debates about genetically
modified organisms or synthetic biology and
all that.
Could you comment on, you know, your answer
to concerns that this would impede things
like GMO labeling if voters wanted it, things
like that?
FROMAN: Right.
There's nothing in there that would impede
any of that.
I mean, our fundamental focus is-whether it's
in TPP or in TTIP-is to underscore the importance
of science-based and risk-based decision-making,
which is already established in the WTO.
These countries have all agreed to that 22
years ago or so, and we want to make sure
that we're implementing that.
We trust science.
Whether they're European scientists, or Japanese
scientists, or wherever the science is done,
we trust science because we think it's a very
sound basis on which to make these decisions.
Our challenge has oftentimes been in countries
where the scientists say something is safe,
but the politicians then vote on safety and
decide whether they think it's safe or not.
And that, I think, is challenge to the rules-based
system that we all agreed to in the WTO.
And so, as-you know, with-this an issue, certainly
a significant issue in TTIP, and you allude
to it in TPP as well.
We're not trying to force anybody to eat anything,
but we do think the decisions about what is
safe ought to made by science, not by politics
and not by protectionism.
And that's our position in both agreements.
JANOW: And that's been true, as you say, since
pre-Uruguay Round, so.
Well, with that, it's wonderful to have you
here.
Please come back.
Please join me in thanking Ambassador Froman.
(Applause.)
(END)